Hey,
what's going on is bill burns time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Dan,
just checking in on you,
seeing how your week's going as you slogging your way through your cubicle life,
something you never wanted,
you know,
but who are you going to blame?
You can't blame society like all of these people on social networks.
Is it ever their fault?
Anyways,
I have a special guest as promised on the Monday morning podcast.
I said,
God damn it.
And I delivered.
We have the amazing,
the unbelievably talented and hilarious Bill Hader,
star of the new incredible show on Hbo,
Barry Starring Henry Winkler.
Stephen Root.
I was my cheat sheet,
which was the one place your girlfriend,
she crushes it.
Sarah Go,
oh my God,
she's amazing.
Yeah,
she's,
she's amazing.
She's amazing.
And uh,
it's eight incredible episodes.
Thank you.
I saw the first two and then my link expired and then I couldn't get it to play.
I got a new link and then I melted down and my wife said,
you're bringing tension.
That was,
that's been my experience so far.
But having said that,
I absolutely loved,
loved the first two weeks
that I saw.
And there's another ad,
the other actor,
they with the alopecia there.
Uh,
Anthony.
Yeah,
Anthony Carrigan.
Oh my God,
no hoe.
Hank [inaudible].
Great Name.
Incredible actor.
So,
um,
I was actually tips to give people background.
I was going to interview all of you guys at the now defunct nerd melt.
Yeah.
That's gone because of that incident I believe.
Because what happened to me,
hey,
yeah.
So you,
you,
you were supposed to come down there with 10 re Steven and uh,
the other guys and uh,
you have a peanut allergy,
has a nut allergy and they gave,
they gave me,
well,
here's the thing,
it's my own.
I blamed myself so I can have almonds.
I'm okay with almonds,
but all the other nuts I'm bad with.
So like all of coffee and Oh,
can I have almond milk in it?
And again,
like a racist,
but with just like nuts.
Right.
Just nuts.
No.
So those are the,
you stay with your own,
you stay with the almonds.
All of these other ones.
Get them out of my house.
All right,
here,
you're a peanut supremacy.
I've never heard of that.
I thought if you had like a peanut allergy,
I
found that out on a movie.
I had something and Whoa,
that has almonds in it and I had it and I go,
I'm fine.
And then I went home and I did an Epi pen and sat there with almonds and ate it
and empty pin.
That's what you take in case you haven't jabbing motion and to do what I do is
stabbing motion into,
you're like,
yeah,
I stat you stab yourself with the Epi pen.
So it takes what?
Like your blood pressure.
So like no,
it just shoots you full of adrenaline basically and then you just,
you're able to breathe.
It gets a big shot of that.
So when you drank the,
so you were supposed to come in and all of a sudden somebody basically gave the
equivalent to you of a couple of days.
They gave me will almond milk,
but it was this fancy coffee place and they were like,
well we have an almond.
The cashew blend that comes in.
I can't have cashews.
So I had that and I took a drink of it backstage,
excited about to go on and I went,
I got to go.
When you drink that,
how quick do you know it's like getting the Cobra?
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like you just know.
You're like,
all right,
that wasn't good.
I need the [inaudible].
You don't get,
you don't get bit by a Cobra and go,
I'm going to wait.
We can do the 20 minutes.
I can do the podcast.
I'm fine.
My legs all black and blue and I can't really feel my feet anymore.
And Yeah,
you bet.
I'm fine.
It was just one Fang.
Yeah,
I'm fine.
And my dad was the biggest bomb.
It was.
My Dad's a giant fan of yours.
So my dad was really excited too.
And he flew in because we had the premiere and so he wanted to see it and I go,
I gotta go.
And he was like,
what?
Oh,
no.
And he's like,
he goes,
you're fine.
Shake it off.
And I go,
no,
no.
And he's like,
you're fine,
you're fine.
I go,
what?
I want to see bill burr?
And I'm like,
well,
I gotta go,
I gotta go.
You can stay here,
go.
And he's like,
oh,
I'll go,
you know,
let's get you some Benadryl and all that stuff.
Okay,
so,
so what happens is you with your throat closes up guy.
Someone ran out and got me Benadryl and that,
that was fine.
And then I got home.
Did he plan bad is like how much are you laboring?
Breathing?
I'm breathing fine.
It's just like I,
it was in my mouth for only a couple of seconds and then I spit it out.
But it was enough to make everything start to kind of,
it was like hives inside your mouth and your throat.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It was awful.
When you take the Benadryl,
how long does it take that out and then you get groggy.
And then I did the Epi pen,
which then makes you all jacked up.
And then I went and did the premiere and yeah.
Sucks.
I'll see you [inaudible] worked on that night.
Yeah,
I had to,
yeah.
It was like HBO was like,
we need you.
So do you travel when you travel?
Do you have those things with you?
At my backpack out right there.
Yeah.
And that's the whole reason I yeah,
you can go.
Yeah.
You get a
prescription for it.
Yeah.
Cause like the writer's room on f is the family,
you know,
when you just get like burned out,
like I can't think of any more funny shit.
Epi Pen.
Just stab you.
Yeah,
let's just do Epi pens.
Yeah.
Well No,
it's like this dumb thing though.
When you do it,
everyone thinks it's,
but it's,
it's,
it's just more,
the motion of it looks more severe than it actually is.
It's just like a little pin prick,
but it's like buried into this.
You go through your pants.
No,
you kind of pull your pants down and go right on your leg and then,
but uh,
so you stab it and then you push,
push the thing down at the same time.
Yeah.
You can't tell me you don't feel a little bit like John Rambo when you do.
No,
you totally do.
Yeah.
You station yourself up.
That's awesome.
But I'm such a wimp that,
um,
you know,
I want you to know you not being there really threw me off my game because I've,
I've never hosted one of those before.
So it was an honor that I got to do it.
And one of my goals was like,
I was just like,
I am not asking Henry Winkler about playing Arthur funds are rally right.
I am going to,
if I'm going to do anything,
I'm going to talk about night shift.
I left you and
nothing,
which,
and then by the end I was just like,
they were helping me through the interview and then somehow I just said,
I go,
you know,
I'm running out of stuff,
but my goal is,
is I'm not bringing up,
you know,
who,
and then he just broken to the character.
Just say it like,
you know,
that character maybe a lot of money and put my kids through college.
I can't do the fonts.
And then I was all excited.
Like,
oh my God,
he did the fonts and he does it.
You.
It's like the,
it's like,
uh,
you know Mickey Mouse showing I have John Malaney said it's like Mickey mouse
showing up or something.
It's like a thing I grew up like,
oh,
that's television is character and heal.
He said it to Alec Berg and I once and Alec cocreative Barry,
he's not a very effusive guy and he was standing behind me and Henry told this
story.
We're getting emotional.
Yeah,
he's,
he's Swedish.
Neither of my Swedish
Swedish,
you know,
it's like,
Oh,
I've done stand up.
I've done staying up through the hole.
Uh,
that whole region up there.
Finland was the funniest one.
Well,
I would just sitting there,
they were trying to solve the problem of the jail.
Like I would sit there and I'm doing the joke and it was just quiet and quiet
and quiet.
And then if somebody is just fine,
it goes,
why didn't you just blah blah blah.
And I was just like,
is that what you fucking guys are doing?
I go,
you don't need to solve these.
This isn't like a self help thing.
It's just she'll just kick your wife out of the house.
Yes.
Battery out in the backyard and say she went to a mother's going to do that.
Yeah,
that was Finland go by.
Definitely noticed it was a huge difference was at the Baltic Sea,
like Norway and Sweden as a certain level of emotionally disconnected and then
when you go to the over there with this spoon with Russia and they actually
defeated Russia and had to give up part of their land because they paired up
with Hitler and that was it,
you know?
Yeah.
They had,
they would between the two craziest people in the last century.
It's like who went to the crazier one?
Which who lost.
Yeah.
Don't ever go there.
I don't know if he,
they went to the crazy one.
They,
they,
they were equals they were peers.
They were
like,
if there was a way that they both could have won the war and lived,
yeah.
I guess the other guy lived right style live.
I don't know shit about history.
Like they could sit back,
like,
you know,
old NBA players,
like when wilt and Bill Russell get together,
they could be talking about murdering people and their knees are bad.
They can't really walk around much.
They're exaggerating their stats.
Yeah.
But no,
they,
yeah,
it was this,
no,
Alec is that
hilarious.
I mean,
he wrote on Seinfeld and curb your enthusiasm.
He's,
he's a very funny guy,
but he's not,
he's very kind of quiet and,
and uh,
Henry did the Fonz,
he just told a story and I said,
Oh,
I had to tell all these people,
you know,
because Henry and life is very kind of hello.
Oh,
that's what makes it when you meet them or you see him just taught.
And that's what makes it even more incredible because that guy came out of this
guy.
Yeah.
He's like,
I was on the phone in
my car,
hands free.
And I'm like,
okay,
being safe,
being safe.
And then you know,
and then it'd be like,
Oh,
you know,
the funds would say,
hey,
but like the Red Sea,
you know,
he would do something and Alec was behind me and he went,
oh my God.
It was the most,
he just went,
I can't,
I can't believe why he,
it was the most diffusive I've ever seen Alex.
He just went,
oh,
I can't believe that.
It gave us chills,
you know?
Well,
because it,
it it like,
like you said,
when you talked to the guy,
it's nowhere.
It's like Mel Blanc.
When Mel Blanc with voices like you,
you'd be like this,
there's no way this guy does bugs bunny or does you send me Sam?
I couldn't hear him.
In any event,
I feel like with him when he's just talking,
it's just like this can't be the guy that played that guy and all of a sudden he
does the voice.
This is hilarious.
Now I'm going to sit here and talking about it.
Fonts for this whole of an interview.
Sorry,
I left you with nothing though because I left and then you were stuck with that.
It sounds to me like you blew off the interview and I'm not buying this whole
fucking stab and yourself than some,
you made the fire.
It was a premiere.
There was no,
there was no fucking nerd melts.
Talk Taco,
some jackasses podcast.
I get it.
Those supermodels,
he's be Oprah premiere for Barry.
No,
it was all like cast group.
Who does checks?
They weren't done.
How have they were working there?
No,
no,
but I,
they had me,
um,
no,
I,
that was a thing where it was one of those things when you leave and then Hbo is
going,
Oh my God.
Well,
you know,
the thing is,
it's his show.
You gotta,
you know gotta be,
well,
what do we got to,
can we send a doctor over there?
Can we do anything?
What can we do?
And they're going old school sending hookers and eight balls.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This is Dr feelgood and yeah,
it's my Bajic briefcase.
All right.
You're going to be up in no time
dining buddy.
Well,
everybody I know that has been watching.
It is just been like,
you know what I love about it and what I wanted to talk to you about is I love
when somebody that's known for doing comedy gets to do some drama stuff because
for some reason they think that a,
I don't know who the comedian was that screwed it up for the rest of us.
I want to know who that person was and also who the person was that fucked up so
bad that we all actors now have to get there like nine hours before you're going
to get
call.
You just sit there with a fake mustache glued on your face.
It's just like,
who fucked up?
Who fucked up fatty Arbuckle?
Who wasn't five fatty Arbuckle just was always,
was this 20 minutes you had 30 hours late,
30 hours lights and now they got to bring you in.
Got to get the Arbuckle rule.
I want all these assholes here.
Now at my worst,
ma'am,
my worst one ever,
I got called,
I was went to a set at four o'clock in the afternoon and I didn't work.
Didn't utter a word until one in the morning.
Oh,
I've done that where I got called on a,
I remember a tropic thunder.
There was this huge a party scene and it was just one of those things where I
just learned that it's all communication where Ben Stiller's directing and Ben
and Ben,
I think he kept saying,
Rob Character's name is rob,
but there's also an actor named rob.
And he was like,
rob should be in there.
Right.
You know,
and the first aid d went,
oh,
Bill's bill's not working day.
So they would wake me up,
oh,
call me flying the colony in.
I would go in at two in the morning and does that in wherever,
shooting like Hawaii or something.
And I'd go in,
put me in makeup,
and I would just sit in my trailer.
And then finally I get tired,
you know,
kind of like,
what am I doing?
You know,
and I'm not in the scene.
And so I would go to set and Ben would go,
the fuck are you doing?
And then two days later,
hey,
we need you to come in.
What's going on in that?
Well,
what are you doing here?
And he goes,
no,
Rob,
rob the actor,
rob,
not the fuck,
you know.
And I showed up twice.
Oh,
it was terrible.
Waiting in those trailers.
I actually understood my dog more.
Yeah.
I was just thinking why does this same fucking sleep all the time?
And it's basically,
if you have nothing to do,
it goes back to sir survival where it's like we're gonna shut down your body and
just store it this energy.
So like the level of tired you get.
But how does my dog,
no,
every episode of the Tyra banks show,
cause that seems to be the only thing on television
or do you go to the trailers?
I've never had the TV work.
It's always like,
oh,
they're going to flat screen TV and hearing it and it never works.
It's just like whatever's signal.
You just hear the other actor next to you clearing their throat every couple of
hours.
Yeah.
On the phone with their agent.
I,
uh,
I'm not going to do that.
They want me to do this.
I'm not going to do it.
Well let's,
let's promote it a little bit here because,
uh,
as far as like,
it's on Hbo.
Okay.
The final episode is this Sunday.
Yeah,
there's eight of them.
And if people want to go back and watch all of them,
I imagined in 2018 HBO has a way to,
yeah,
I was saying in an HBO go you,
if you have that you can go check it out.
And I think,
uh,
Amazon,
Hulu,
those places,
well I'm old school in that.
I like to watch an episode.
I liked the old way.
Well you watched it and then you had to wait a week for it to come out and then,
and then another one went and,
and like,
like,
um,
I don't know
all the shows that I watch,
you try to guess what was going to happen and now like there's all these great
shows that just dump it on.
People just sit down.
It's like,
it's like the greatest bottle of wine ever.
And you like shotgun.
It was amazing.
And then like what else can I have now?
And it's just,
and I also have,
I feel for like the amount of work that was put into this because that's what
happens with the fucking cartoon I'm doing,
which just this,
I actually did a cartoon after because of those getting called at four in the
afternoon,
not work until one.
I'm like,
dude,
fuck this live action shit.
I'm going to do a car to,
why?
Just show up in a baseball hat and sweatpants and I didn't realize that it was
like 90 times slower and then the thing comes out and people will watch it all
in one night.
That's great.
When's the next season coming out?
It's just like,
I can't,
well,
might as well just be a movie.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
Oh,
put it in the theater.
I don't know.
But I like it that you do this and then for eight weeks people are talking
about,
there's like a level of a high intensity level of
ego.
I have no idea where this is going to go.
It's fun having people come up to me,
you know,
my kid's school or whatever going,
hey,
so this is what's going to happen,
right.
If I'm going to kill you.
Yeah.
One guy came up and he was like,
Stephen Root.
He's a figment of his imagination.
Right.
It's not real.
Oh yeah.
He might be right.
You know,
I got you figured out ass all right.
Yeah.
I used to watch lost.
I know where you're going with this.
Yeah.
The,
it's all figments of a,
some mouse as imagination,
right?
Yeah.
It's all a figment to get eight seasons or whatever the hell it is.
But anyway,
you know,
something I actually,
uh,
something I want to bring up before I forget is that,
you know,
uh,
that you're from Tulsa,
Oklahoma,
and I was telling you earlier that that is one of my favorite cities to perform
standup.
And they got the Brady theater there,
which evidently some ridiculous race riot happened.
Really?
I guess so.
I mean,
I walked in,
there was a white guy,
I'm like,
Oh,
this has a nice vibe.
It just feels like really great.
And that's why is this so comfortable?
Yeah.
And it's,
um,
it's,
and then they've got all this great cause all these,
all these people who'd never been there.
When I told him I'm in Tulsa,
Oklahoma,
everybody's was like,
oh Jesus Christ,
you know,
what are you gonna fucking go ride a bull out there?
Like go cow tipping and they don't understand like how like the,
the food there is incredible massive amounts of hipsters.
It's the exact opposite thing that you would a picture.
But that old theater there.
Yeah.
Guys.
That George Carlin there once I remember there was the first comedy show ever.
So what year did you see him?
I don't remember.
I was young.
I remember my dad.
It was a thing where I got to get snuck into the thing,
but my dad,
God,
I don't remember how to be in the 80s I saw him the too.
Yeah.
And I started seeing him and just my face hurting from laughing and just it,
and not knowing that he did like two hours or I don't know what it was.
It was just super long.
But to me,
I was like,
oh,
keep going,
you know,
and uh,
and just leaving on this high and just going,
wow.
That was,
that have an effect that you like at that point,
did you already know you wanted to get into comedy or,
no,
I mean,
I,
to me that just seemed like a,
I mean,
I was so sewing,
I didn't,
I,
and I still,
I have very anxious and having to get up in front of people and so I,
I,
the idea of going up there alone and telling jokes and how quick he was,
but I loved watching stand up my dad's giant fan of Stan to stand up and so,
and in the 80s and that,
you know,
every TV,
you had the a and e the evening at the Improv.
You the MTV half hour kind hour.
Those watches,
I saw those.
I mean,
I would run into like Jeff Garlin and be like,
do you remember used to do the,
I think the Adam West Adam West [inaudible] Bagel and he gets hit with a you
half hour comedy on TV.
Yeah.
And he went,
what,
how did,
you know?
And then when I met Judd Apatow for the first time,
I go,
you used to do a bit about,
uh,
you know,
your nose,
uh,
you know,
being stuffed up and how it switches,
you get congested in one nostril and goes in a an astrolabe.
Yeah,
though I remember that.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
that's usually I can freak people out.
I remember,
I forget the name of the comedian,
but he had this great bit he was talking about,
I ran into the guy,
I don't even remember his name,
but I was one of my favorite bits that I saw from one of those evening at the
Improv.
And he was talking about how he was the youngest kid in this big family and how
strict the parents were with the older kids.
And by the time it got down to him,
it was,
uh,
you know,
it was basically the only rule was no heroin in the living room.
And then one of my favorite tax of all time,
it was just like,
Brian,
you're not using one of the good spoons.
And that was just like,
you know,
for a clean joke and all I really loved,
I got to actually run into him and tell him.
And I remember just talking to that guy and him just looking at me like,
how the fuck does this kid,
oh my God,
Bob Nelson,
that guy would,
there was a guy,
Bob Nelson,
I'm a dual crazy.
And then I saw him open for Rodney Dangerfield right after back to school,
back to school.
Came out through that summer at great woods,
Eh,
in Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
I saw Rodney Dangerfield.
And then a few weeks later I saw Eddie Murphy on the Rato and the weather girl
weathered girls opened up,
they sing,
it's raining men and they were big girls.
And I remember he came out and was doing all these jokes about,
I got to check out the stage because the weather girls can fuck up the stage
back when you could fat shame people.
And um,
he had like the purple suit on.
And all of that stuff.
He always close with his daddy didn't tinker toys and the food,
the,
the toy thing.
Remember that the,
I don't remember what he closed.
I mean,
Eddie,
we would eat our tinker toys.
Any that whole thing that he would do is,
cause that was a thing seeing raw,
which now you watch raw and you're like,
Geez,
there's some stuff you can do now.
But that,
uh,
that and bear to him,
I know,
but it's just lazy as 30 years ago.
But you go like,
uh,
yeah.
At SNL you would watch something to all,
you guys got to watch raw and then they would come back and go,
why did you find that funny?
It was so offensive and everything and go,
wow.
Oh Man.
You know,
uh,
what about the thing at the end?
You know,
I would just try to concentrate on the thing I found.
Oh No.
When I watched that,
it makes me sad that he stopped because he was 25 years old.
And,
uh,
when he was talking about,
you know,
the level success he got to and thinking about getting married and see Johnny
Carson getting divorced and all of that stuff and saying,
well,
you know,
women get half,
that's bullshit.
No,
somebody goes when we get half and then when one goes,
that's right.
And he goes,
Nah,
that's bullshit.
And it was like he was going to that next level where it's like,
oh,
now this guy is going to,
you know,
start saying what he thinks about all this stuff.
Cause you know,
the delirious was amazing,
but it was uh,
you know,
Ralph Kramden having sex with,
yeah,
yeah.
That stuff,
all that stuff.
And then all of a sudden he was like,
you've seen this guy finding his voice and uh,
and then,
I mean,
who knew that I would go see him and that that was actually like
the farewell tour.
Yeah.
Well,
I think when he did the thing at the end of raw was the thing I saw,
you know,
as a,
when I was young and it went,
wow,
he's just by himself mean you might as well buy.
It'd be by himself in his room.
You know what I mean?
It was like he went into this other place,
you know?
It wasn't like jokes,
you know what I mean?
It was like talking,
he's just talking and he just went to this place and it's the thing I'm never as
funny.
I the funniest I'll ever be as in the lunch room with my friends and they were
all funnier than me.
You know what I mean?
I remember in high school with his funny than I was way funnier than me and I
still see those guys and they'll just like,
they'll send me a text about,
one of my friends hated three billboards.
That movie and his tax made me laugh harder than anything that I've read.
Any comedian.
I know.
All I do is hang around with comedy people and I'm like,
what?
You know,
he works at a windows store and Oklahoma someplace.
It was so funny
or just how they live their life.
I got a buddy of mine,
uh,
Joe Rosa was open and for me and you know,
it was after the show we did in Boston.
I got all my boss,
you know,
hanging out or whatever and uh,
one of my buddies offered to buy a round the drinks,
they're all ordering drinks and my buddy Joe ordered a white Russian and my
friend was just done with him
and he came up and he goes,
dude,
what's up with your boy?
I go,
what's the matter?
He goes,
he just sorted a white Russian and I didn't really think about it.
I was like,
I ain't know he drinks white Russians.
He likes,
you know,
whatever.
That movie with the dude.
He,
he likes to pick the bass.
Yeah,
he's a big Lebowski.
I only think of anything about it.
And then the end of the night I'm walking back with Joe.
He's just like,
hey,
you know,
like hanging out with friends.
He goes,
yeah,
there's cools yet.
He said,
well,
what are you friends was,
he was like really friendly and he was like talking to me.
Then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
he just stopped talking to me.
And it was,
it was all based on the fact that he ordered a white Russian and we were well
into our thirties,
like late thirties.
And this guy still to this day and I remember a long time,
I don't trust that guy.
I don't,
I don't know anybody like that.
I remember a long time ago,
he for some reason was giving the responsibility to watch the house of this
married couple.
And of course he immediately has this all over there
and we're getting hammered and um,
and he's taking care of the house and went down into the basement and there was
some sort of a faucet nozzle is something you had to turn on or off and,
and,
and the lady left the post it note on it saying you might have to,
uh,
turn it a little hard on.
My husband said it's a little fussy and my buddy just went up and just
immediately turned it with no problem at all.
And you just,
you just [inaudible] this guy said
we're in his house and he probably,
he just said that to his wife just being,
you know,
gentlemanly to a woman and then this might friend just totally judge this guy
that he was,
he was not man like his man.
That's what I love about my friends.
Back to how easily you could lose your man card and you have no idea.
And they won't even tell you why they just stopped talking to you.
Oh,
it's the worst.
When my friends,
they visited the set of Barry and you know,
I'm doing all these things or whatever and I have an assistant,
oh,
it's over.
She walked over,
here's your,
here's your coffee.
Well man,
you can get your own coffees now.
What?
What do you think machines?
The machines right there,
dude,
just go over and get your own God damn coffee bill.
And I'm like,
well,
I'm focusing on,
I don't give a shit.
You go,
bro,
why you making her get your,
and I'm like,
no,
not,
you're right,
you're right.
I should be the machines right there.
I don't know.
You're now.
You're right.
You know what I mean?
I just feel like an asshole.
And then I'm like,
why did I invite you here to,
you know,
uh,
make me feel bad and then,
hey man,
did you try the dessert?
I,
and I'm trying not to eat anything bad cause you know the guys in the military
or were like,
oh fuck you man.
Now you're dining now.
And I'm like,
oh hey.
Yeah,
they just keep you real.
I and I ended up,
I just go back harder at them.
I can't see,
you know?
Yeah.
We're really trying to work on my man tits.
Like who have the mess?
The only way to keep them off you dude.
I had another friend,
the exact same party he was telling me.
He was telling this story.
He's going,
where are you staying?
I told him the hotel I was staying at p and he was a construction guy.
Goes,
oh I worked on that.
He goes,
crazy story.
We will,
we will put in a flagpole or something up and he goes stiff.
The fucking cable broke.
This guy was underneath directed and that cable broken just came slamming down
on this guy.
Oh Geez.
I go,
Jesus Christ,
did he die?
And he goes,
He was in fucking pieces.
And I co,
well,
what happened?
He goes,
oh guys were puking.
Some people jumped in their truck and drove away and they got,
his dad was there,
he had a heart attack.
So we're all just sitting there like dead silence.
And then he just out to know where he goes.
Ah,
kid was kind of a dose and then he goes,
he goes to his dad was a good shit and that actually broke the tension.
And everybody started laughing.
And I just remember thinking like,
you couldn't teach somebody no in an acting class.
How to take this somebody to such a dark place.
And he sensed it.
No,
he's sense that's a laugh meeting to come.
And he knew exactly where to go.
Intuition.
My friend.
Uh,
I used to be a PA,
I was a production assistant for a long time.
And then I worked on this movie,
James Dean and an invented life,
or James Franco played James Dean and this Guy Jason Lt Airy,
who's now a big first Aidy now,
but he was a PA.
And again,
what we're talking about,
he had a,
he had a real like Rambo knife,
like he got it from the props truck and he's just taking chunks out of this tree
with it and he's just hitting this tree with his giant knife and we're all kind
of sitting there.
Why?
And he's just bullshitting with us because like,
look at this fucking thing.
Wow.
Look at them like,
look,
it's really,
it's like an ex,
you know,
standing
out.
And this other guy,
Bill Hardy,
this big guy walking over and he's another PA smoke.
Are you guys okay?
And Jason,
he's weird.
This keys.
He pretends like he's going to stab him.
He just goes,
hey,
don't fuck it.
That's not funny.
Don't do that.
That's not cool.
So bill walks away,
the props guy comes over and goes,
I have that same knife but it's the exact same knife but it's retractable,
it's plastic,
it's fake,
you know,
and he goes,
get it to me.
He takes it and he does the best piece of acting I've ever seen.
Just totally calm pretending to like,
you know,
cut it the tree,
do everything.
Just waiting for bill to come back.
Bill walks back,
hey,
how's it going?
Hey how you doing?
And he does the,
does the thing again and then just rears back and stabs him in the
just saw God and bill goes,
why?
His reaction was why you just murdered
flesh.
He legitimately was like,
my friend just murdered
all down laughing and we felt bad.
And I've told that story to other people on the go,
that's horrible.
That's not nice at all.
And I go,
I know,
but if you were there,
it was the funniest thing I think I had ever seen.
And because you're literally got to see,
what would your friend do,
what would he do if he died?
He would say,
why if he got murdered.
But then Jason,
to your point,
the reason I thought of it was that he was such a good actor.
He was just like,
you couldn't have taught like anybody else.
I think you would get it and they would want to run over to him and go,
hey,
look in the night.
And then,
you know what I mean?
But I wouldn't,
I would have taken the knife and walked up to him and done it.
But he had the patience to keep like,
no,
I have to keep this,
this,
this lie up.
Or he was pretending to do that and we sat there waiting for him for like 15
minutes and then he kind of would meander back like,
no,
we can't call him over.
We can't do this.
You know,
I wouldn't be able to keep a straight face.
I'm going to war first.
Hey,
when you watch somebody do something like that as an actor,
do you get something out of that?
Watching a guy like that?
Yeah.
You kind of go,
oh wow.
The patients are so much of it too is just kind of impersonating people are,
you know,
or doing nothing.
That was the thing he did that was good was he didn't do anything.
Do you know what I mean?
He just was doing what he did before and he kind of instinctively knew like,
well that's how,
that's the best way to do this.
That's the best way to set the trap is and make it look like nothing happened.
Instead of,
I would have gone over there,
I've been,
hey bill,
come back or whatever.
Are those some of your favorite actors?
Are you a character actor guys?
Far as like the guys that you watch because you're acting on the series is,
is phenomenal.
I can't,
I kept calling,
uh,
my wife and going,
look,
this is like the bestest,
I'm telling you,
it's like the best work I've seen and I love all the stuff that you've done.
Oh,
but like this to actually,
I love it when they give a funny guy a to show that,
hey,
I can do these other things too.
Yeah.
So I was just curious,
now that I see that you have that in the toolbox,
like who are some of your favorite actress?
Um,
well,
I mean it's not,
I mean the,
I had a tape that,
this is kind of everybody,
but,
uh,
I had a VHS tape that had taxi driver and raging bull on it and I would just
watch those a bunch and just watch Robert Deniro in those movies.
He just does,
it's kind of what retirement,
he doesn't do much,
but he did enough,
you know,
it was like he just,
the way my,
it was behavior,
but to be honest,
like I like,
uh,
you know,
um,
I like a lot of actors,
but I was always more excited by the story.
I might watch a movie for a story,
but to me it's just more,
it's more about observing behavior of people.
You know,
you watch like a documentary or I'd watch a guy like Jason l tre do that thing
or whatever,
but it was the actors who could modulate behavior instead of pushing and making
it like a performance,
you know?
Right.
There's a movie called CAS.
It's this British movie from the late sixties and then this is non-actor,
this kid in it who's phenomenal and it just is because it's all just very
genuine.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
okay.
It's time for a little bit of advertising.
Oh,
look who's back.
It's all zip.
Right.
Screwed up.
Talk about the challenges of finding great talent and how the way you went about
it just did not work.
Oh,
was inefficient.
You know,
I tried to dig down deep into myself to try to be a good comedian and it turned
out all I had was a bunch of Shit and Dick Jokes down there and it was really
tough.
And then I use zip recruiter and all of a sudden,
you know,
I started talking about Pussy Toe.
Am I,
my comedy went to I,
I don't fucking hire people,
but I know this app,
this,
is this an APP,
this product,
this service.
Okay,
let's go with that.
I know it works.
Ziprecruiter knew there was a smarter way,
so they built a platform that finds the right job candidates for you.
These invitations have revolutionized how you find your next hire.
In fact,
80% of employees who post a job on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate through
the site and just one day and Zip,
Eh,
uh,
doesn't stop there.
They even spotlight the strongest applications you received so you never miss a
great match.
The right candidates around out there
recruit is how you find them.
Businesses of all sizes trust ZipRecruiter for their hiring needs.
Right now my listeners can try Xanax.
That's right.
They can use it for free.
You can try it for free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/prayer one more time.
Hi,
the smartest way to hire
well coups here.
Oh,
don't do me Andy's beyond days.
I'm sitting near my fucking car.
Bluedot to to me undies.
Me,
Andy's.
I'm driving out to a bar.
I'm going to get hammered at the bar.
Take your piss and my soft under way.
Am I balls,
a field grade and on diesel.
Dry it up.
You don't need no more adult diapers.
Candies are made with the sustainably sourced material from beechwood trees made
out of trees.
Man,
they're naturally soft.
Fiber makes a fabric that won't sag down or write up.
Trust me,
once you got a pair on,
you'll get it.
And if you're already part of the me undies family,
tell your friends about it through their referral program though.
It's like Amway,
but with fucking panties,
they get a discount and you'll get a store credit.
It's a win win.
Me,
Andy's is,
sure you'll love their first pair is so sure you'll love their first pair that
if you're not happy,
they'll do whatever they can to get you the right pair and if they can't keep
them and they'll refund you.
So it's really risk free.
Free to try the best underwear ever.
Still not sure if,
wow me on ds has a deal for my listeners,
first time purchasers,
get 20% off their first pair of me undies and free shipping.
Get your ass over to [inaudible] dot com and treat yourself to get 20% off your
first pair and free shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
burr unbelievable how hot your car gets.
The second you shut it off and keep the windows and doors shut.
Oh,
look who's here.
When you shop online,
do you suddenly turn into a tab hoarder loading dozens and dozens of new tabs on
your browser and search of a Promo Code,
just one that works.
Afraid to close any of them in fear of missing out on a deal before you crash
your browser yet again.
Try.
Hi Renee,
honey.
It's the free browser.
Add on.
That's overnight that over 9 million people are using every day to save money
while they shop online in two clicks.
Add honey to any browser for free.
Then shop like you normally do.
Honey Scans and tests,
millions of coupons in the background and checkout high ne automatically applies
the best coupon.
Honey never means honey.
It never does.
Time magazine calls honey.
Basically ev basically free money.
Over 9 million people have used oh honey,
every day and together they've saved millions of dollars.
There's no reason not to add honey to your browser.
Today.
I'm running out of ways to say it.
It's free.
Just takes two clicks to install and will save you tons of money.
Get hunting for free@joinhoney.com slash bird that's two words.
Join.
Hi Auntie
mmm.com/bird to start saving with honey today.
That's joined honey.com/burr right?
This people next door working on the house.
They think I'm fucking crazy.
Alright.
Helix.
Everybody.
There's nobody on the planet like you,
so why would you buy a fucking mattress built for everyone else?
Next,
please mention all the talking points below what I'm Gunna,
you wrote it.
I'm going to read it.
Uh,
working with the world's leading sleep experts,
helic sleep developed a mattress that customize,
that's customized to your specific height,
weight,
and sleep preferences so you can get the best God damn sleepy life at an
unbelievable price.
Here's how it works.
Go to hell.
Heloc,
sleep.com fill out their two minutes sleep quiz,
and they'll design your custom mattress.
They can even customize each side for you and your partner in 2018 he likes
sleep,
has taken customized sleep to the next level with the hallux pillow,
the all new pillows are fully adjustable so you can achieve corporate comfort
regardless of sleep position of body type.
Do you want to kill your wife?
They got a pillow for that to helic sleep has the eye.
That's just a joke.
He likes sleep,
does not condone any fucking violence to luxury spa.
has thousands of five star reviews,
plus you get a hundred nights to try them out.
Tell them which hand you jerk off with.
They'll have a little elbow indentation on that side of the mattress.
Go to Helix [inaudible] dot com slash burr right now and you'll get up to $125
towards your new fucking mattress.
That's helix sleek.com/birth for up to $225 off your mat is how it looks.
sleek.com/bird h e l.
I x.
Sleep
actors w when they'll,
while I'm playing a new guy,
so the guy can't walk like me and they'll come up with like a walk.
Yeah.
I don't know those droves it or bring him up again.
And he told him who was talking about John Travolta one time you saw him and
John Travolta was like,
well,
Vinny Barbarino walked like this,
Vincent Vega walk like this.
And it's just like,
dude,
he does the walks.
And I was thinking of the little acting that I've done.
It's like every character I've done walks like me,
they would have to rewrite it.
He's,
he's a serial killer from Boston and he's a,
yeah,
he's a Hawaiian guy from Boston.
Yeah.
Cowboy from Boston.
I did one where they,
they couldn't justify why it wasn't from the Midwest.
So they said you went to college in Boston and he picked up the accent,
but still,
for some reason he came back here.
He didn't go back to the exit that he used.
He was raised by some assholes from Boston,
but in the middle watches a lot of reality TV.
There's always the loud Boston guy.
So,
um,
he likes watching interviews with the Mark Wahlberg and yeah,
but he,
he doesn't have,
he doesn't have an accent in Mark Wong.
No.
Yeah.
Like I,
I'm always amazed at how,
uh,
forget that he's,
he can,
he can knock that out somehow.
And I've watched some,
like I started out with Patrice O'Neal and Dane Cook and I saw like an old day
and cook standup thing in the last couple of years I saw it and in like the mid
nineties,
he had really big
time.
Boston actually now he doesn't.
Oh Wow.
Like I don't know how,
I think you're either one of those people like you just sort of like,
if he gets somewhere new,
you just sort of,
it just floats away or it's just stuck in you.
I think I'm,
I'm sort of,
I mean I don't have to work on it.
Oh yeah.
People work.
That's what a read of it.
People do work on it to get rid of it.
And it's weird.
We have bill Hader here from Eric.
I am going to pronunciate hi.
I'm from Boston,
Massachusetts now I think.
But yeah,
it's weird.
Big where it,
but I don't know.
Yeah.
It's like I saw this cooking show recently and this guy,
he was doing something,
you know,
this fucking guy's traveling.
He Goes,
Boston,
you come here for a beer and a beating,
and I just moved.
I was looking at my life.
I go,
Oh,
you go to look at the foliage.
It's just like,
how many times did you watch good will hunting before you went there to steam
your asparagus that you felt you had to go that hard?
You know,
it's like,
there's also MIT,
there's Harvard hate,
tasty,
putting our hasty pudding.
There's a lot of like,
you know,
you could go get some oysters,
oysters,
beer in a beating because they all right.
I lived there for 27 years.
I never took a PT.
I walked away from fights and I was fine with it.
Yeah,
you're tougher than me.
Your Dad was angrier than my dad.
You win.
I'm Outta here.
Steamier his spirit.
Yeah.
We'll get a little poached egg on top of it.
I fucking hate the flu network now.
They used to just have people they're cooking and then teach you how to cook.
And then it became,
you had to have a personality and I,
and I respect his cooking,
but I blamed that fucking emerald.
Luke [inaudible].
He's the guy I'm going to fucking God damn right.
And he had a studio audience in a band.
I used to be the,
it's an editor and a lot of those shows like iron chef America.
It was a,
I don't get it done.
Then I can show you supposed to be relaxing and loving thing that you do and
they take it.
It's like death.
You got to make waffles.
We got stones and,
and carpet.
How the fuck am I going to do this?
And how the fuck I'm a Mario.
Let's see what you got.
And I'm like,
oh.
We used to have a thing of a Bobby flay,
a lag electric
shooting himself.
He accidentally electrocuted himself.
It was really fun.
We did.
Yeah,
they cut it from the thing,
but he grabbed a ladle and something happened and he just went and just dropped
out of frame.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We hit.
The other thing of him,
it is his heart stopped.
Nobody dropped and then kind of came up in a daze and we were,
uh,
he always seemed like he had interjection to me because he'd always be like,
okay,
today we're going to make,
it's just like,
dude,
go off camera and Burp.
Because I liked him.
I like all of those guys.
They all taught me what little I know.
But like I,
I w I used to watch molto Mario [inaudible] all the time,
which to me was the perfect one.
It's like you went over his house and he cooked for you.
Yeah.
It was like being his friend.
And then all of a sudden it just became like that fucking guy on iron chef.
Yeah.
Or the diners drive ins and dives guy,
which is hilarious because like he just looks so burnt out on that show.
Yeah.
What's his name?
A Guy,
Guy Fieri.
It just says what you're doing.
Like you could make like a peanut butter and jelly sandwich.
Okay.
You'll put some peanut butter on the bread and okay.
And you get some jam in there.
That's going to take a little edge off the peanut butter and he makes so much
money.
So much money.
Oh my God.
It's the get the hard top.
Cause he's going to die as skin care.
It looks like a fucking lobster.
This is coming from a redhead.
I'm telling you.
He's got to get some sunblock.
Um,
so what,
what can we talk about about everybody?
Because this is a podcast.
It's not like people are dipping in here.
Yeah.
People know that this show is on,
so they can,
uh,
HBO is their Hbo streaming.net.org.
Yeah,
I mean,
you go to,
well,
no,
I mean Amazon or Hulu or uh,
uh,
HBO go is the thing.
I want to be able to go,
yeah,
it's great.
What would be bad for you?
Where should they watch it?
Wherever they want.
I don't.
Okay.
I wasn't sure.
Louie had his show on Fx.
It would be like,
you know,
please,
can you please watch it?
So I get credit for people like watching the advertiser because everybody would
then record it and then fast forward.
I don't know.
I know.
Yeah,
they,
I mean,
to me it's just,
yeah,
just watched hope.
He watched the show.
Hbo Has Been Amazing to work with the fact that we could go in and pitch this
show to them and we're pitching a half hour comedy and the two movies I
mentioned or taxi driver and unforgiven and that's how do they react to it?
Like you coming in and think,
okay it's bill Hader.
This is going to be funny actually and might have is going,
yeah we come in with this and they go and to their credit they were really
excited about it.
It actually made them more excited than how many places did you,
did you pitch this show?
There's just HBO because I had a deal with them and so I had this kind of
development deal with them and,
and I was shooting train wreck actually in the whole time I was on a train wreck
going,
what have you know,
what am I going to do?
I have this deal now with Hbo,
but I got to write a show.
And so I met with Alec Berg and then we came up with this.
And then I remember pitching it to them and thinking,
well,
if they don't like it,
then I'm like,
well,
this is what I would rather want to do it.
If I could do anything,
I can do this.
And um,
they,
the,
the fact that they were the ones going,
oh,
you know,
I said,
the violence has to be very real.
It's not fun having my own,
the violence is not funny at all.
When he fights people,
I like it to feel real.
I just don't,
I don't want it to be cool,
you know?
And uh,
they are absurd.
Yeah.
Like weekend at Bernie's jokes,
you know what I mean?
Like,
which you could easily do in this,
you know,
there's a lot of times where you,
there's a scene in episode three where I have to strangle a guy and there's,
there's in his backyard,
there's all these,
a child's,
you know,
kid toys and stuff.
And I remember Alec Berg and I were shooting that scene and I said,
you know,
any other place they would be like,
hey,
can we make it funny?
Can you kill him with
the kids jump rope or,
you know,
can we get some jokes in there?
You know what I mean?
And it's like,
no it's not.
I feel like the merger is going to be too depressing.
It's like it should be,
no,
no.
But he should kill him.
He should still kill them.
But just funny,
you know,
and you're like,
no,
but,
uh,
we can't do that.
I said this before the podcast,
you know,
that's why I could never really watch.
I watched Dexter cause I liked the performances,
but I couldn't fully commit to it cause I could just hear the industry note.
Whereas like they went,
he's a serial killer and it's just like,
well how can we root for that?
And it's just like,
all right,
he just kills the bad people.
He's a serial killer with a good heart.
And then I just was,
I just never was able,
well that's the hard thing.
That's been the nice thing with Barry,
at least as HBO,
you know,
when we would turn in the drafts,
when we get to later in the season,
especially,
it starts to get a very definitely is not just killing the good people,
you know,
are bad.
The bad people,
he's killing it.
You know,
I gotta go home and I got to see,
you know,
it,
it gets terrible and where he,
he,
he ends up going,
is,
is a pretty rough,
but it was it that was always just being honest to that guy.
You know what I mean?
And that,
that's the thing that HBO has been great about is it,
we'll say,
hey,
is this too much?
And they go,
well,
what else did you going to do?
You know,
they see it from a character standpoint.
They're like,
well,
what's his choice?
You know,
I saw it the two episodes and I
actually felt for the guy as far as like how he became,
that's another thing.
Like he just,
he's just not like,
oh,
okay.
He,
Joseph's born a psycho.
It's like,
no,
this guy went to Afghanistan,
Afghanistan,
did what he did over there and then got into this line of work where he's a hit
man and he basically wants to get out of it.
And uh,
and,
and just Henry Winkler's characters with like the acting class.
And I took a bunch of acting classes.
I had a lot of,
I had some great acting teachers and I had,
but,
but there was was some,
you know,
when they became like the guru and um,
I can't remember this woman's name and I only audited her class.
I audited two classes.
I'm in one on one class.
I audited,
it,
turned out it was Scientology.
Oh really?
Oh,
it was hilarious.
I went in there,
this actor who was in Scientology,
he goes,
oh,
you need an acting class.
And she sent me there and it was acting class,
but it was also like Scientology.
So,
which I felt like she should've said,
right.
That should have been,
it's acting,
but there's a little extra thing.
So I go there,
I go there and I remember,
uh,
we were sitting there and the,
and the guy teaching the class goes,
does anybody have,
uh,
any news they want to walk,
you know,
share with the class.
And someone would raise their hand and be like,
Oh,
I,
uh,
you know,
I just book a three episode arc on a,
who gives a fuck on ABC?
And then the whole crew,
the whole audience,
like ridiculously lab or go
like this positive.
And,
but it was crazy how cultish and I,
I was sitting there like,
what the fuck?
Right.
It's like five people did that and then they go,
hey,
we have,
we have two people auditing the class.
Uh,
this guy,
he's,
he's just fresh here from New York.
He's,
he's an actor,
he's trying to get some parts,
blah,
blah.
Please welcome bill burr.
And they fake clapped.
Like I won a lifetime achievement award.
I remember my face turned red.
I was embarrassed.
So,
you know,
and then I saw the seeds and the actors would go and everything.
And then during the break,
like I remember the teacher was looking at me and goes,
well,
so was that,
was that too much?
Did I push?
Was that,
was I pushing?
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
So then I went in and I sat down with them and they were just,
and they just kept saying everything was their own.
We have our own parking,
we have our own security,
we our own this.
And I swear to God,
I said,
Jesus Christ,
I feel like I'm joining a cult.
Like I was trying to make a joke and he kind of looked at me and his eyes were
like going from my right and my left that red.
I said,
what the fuck is going on?
So I got out of there and then I went down to this,
God,
I swear to God,
this is true.
Went down to the comedy club and I mentioned,
I said,
yeah,
I took this fact and class because the actors were really good,
but it was,
there was this just this fucking weird vibe.
And then I told them like the name of the acting class,
this guy goes,
dude,
that's fucking Scientology.
And uh,
I dunno,
I kind of felt like,
you know,
the next time I saw that person I had that vibe.
Like they put something in my drink,
right?
Like you should have said,
I don't listen guys.
Here's the thing.
Like I don't judge side.
Like I hate when people act like,
oh my God,
those people are out of their fucking minds.
It's like my religion is out of their fucking minds.
It's just they got enough people right where they can act cool now and they
don't care if you leave.
Like Scientology needs people.
So they got it,
you know,
they got to lock in a room or whatever it is.
If you need to say this is where you're going,
you need to say like,
by the way,
you're going to a church.
I liked how they had their own network now to come back cause that one woman did
like the Sh
Ramney or whatever.
She did all this episodes about how crazy that was.
But I always feel like there's another actor that could do the one about the
Catholic church.
Yeah.
They Bang and kids and they made it seem like it was okay.
And that was the thing.
And you bought into it.
Um,
we're getting off track here.
Oh man,
that's great.
What I'm trying to do is I just don't want to fucking sit here and ask you about
SNL and all of that shit that I know.
You've answered a Zillion,
a zillion times.
No,
I'm loving this.
that's every a thing I go to is like the word Stefan from or whatever,
you know.
So how did you come up with that?
And we'll come up with,
so,
um,
I will tell you my favorite thing I ever saw you do was laughing uncontrollably.
Well,
uh,
it was a lock.
The locker room thing.
Oh,
a foretaste.
Yeah.
Oh my coffers.
He told me about that.
You literally the towel.
I have a towel wrapped around my phobia.
It's crazy.
Cause you know why?
Cause Forte did this dance and he did it at the table read on Wednesday.
And I just said I can't,
there's no way I'm going to be able to make it through that.
That's too fine because he's a coach trying to get us all riled up to go back
into the second half of the game and to get us riled up.
He does this herb Albert,
this dance is her bowel
and he does his dance.
And then,
and uh,
and then so yeah,
then I saw before we went on air,
I go,
hey,
will,
can you just do it for me a couple of times just in my dressing room.
Can you just do it so I can like laugh and get it out?
That's great.
Can I just get it out?
So he did it,
but then on air he added a move courses
cause he added this thing and he went like that.
Like he couldn't hear me and,
uh,
and I lost it.
I just completely lost it.
And I started going and then I remember remembered the Degas was next to me.
I don't know,
cause I started going and then Keenan Thompson started going,
cause we just
lost it me straight face.
He Kinda,
he starts to put a towel around his face he gets,
cause I just,
but I completely lost it cause for it,
it also was just,
it was such a forte thing,
forte,
just,
he's not like I'm on,
you know,
he's one of those guys very well.
Hey Man,
I just very cool chill guy.
And then he would do these ideas or something.
What happened to him and you go,
where is that that he's,
I know he would make me laugh that whole period,
all of those like you are you and you're one of those guys like that was like,
thank you.
That was like murderers row.
He,
he,
he had uh,
he pits.
He goes,
I'm a bill,
I'm going out with a movie and I know it's the movie you're doing.
He was wanting to do a movie about a two brothers who,
who's switch bodies.
And I go,
yeah.
And he goes,
here's the thing,
they're identical.
It
doesn't matter.
I go,
okay.
how do people know that they switched body as well?
That's the joke is everyone acts like,
well,
you're acting differently.
That's not like you,
but they're just acting there.
These two boring guy.
So tell him that he would sustain that for heat for 90 minute out.
And I was like,
he told me that and I laugh for,
I just want to,
where the hell did you come with that?
And you know,
I'm going to write this movie about these two guys.
So yeah,
he's just a genius and a great guy too.
But yeah,
no,
I felt very lucky when I was there with all those people,
Kristin and,
and uh,
Andy and Fred Armisen and all those guys.
I mean,
it was crazy.
Yeah.
And you guys have all gone on to do stuff.
So right now are you,
uh,
are you,
when do you start back up with the next season or do you get the writing it
right now?
We're writing season two right now.
Oh God.
Did you get any of the,
how much of a break did you get any kind of bit of a break?
Yeah,
I mean we finished all this in August,
so Barry was done in August.
Oh.
Then it starts airing and then,
you know,
we opened up a writer's room and then,
HBO uh,
told us,
you know,
yeah,
you guys can,
you know,
we do more.
Is it,
it's going to be another eight as of right now,
who knows?
We might change that,
but as of right now it's eight.
I kind of liked that people,
I like being able to craft eight episodes and kind of make it a very,
you know,
kind of a tight season,
and story.
Back in the day when there was a great album,
a lot of times it was eight songs.
Yeah.
Then when the 10 song came out,
it's like,
all right,
here's the fucking valid,
just trying to fill it.
I get it.
It's the same thing with TV in a way where you go,
Oh wow,
now we're going to watch an episode that's all about,
you know,
the gardener or something and you go,
I don't care about this.
You know,
I want to know.
I don't want to,
I want to know what else is going on JD that I don't consider that
groundbreaking.
I'm just like how you guys wanted an episode off.
I think the series regulars are bitching about their contracts.
That guy,
but we got to keep the train moving so let's do something about it.
that guy,
guess what?
You're starring in the show.
This what asshole you're carrying the shelf and if it goes down,
you never play a gardener in this town again.
You piece of shit.
Um,
well anyways,
uh,
thank you so much for uh,
for coming on.
Amen.
Oh,
my head hurts.
I'm laughing so much good.
But no,
it was great.
That's all my interviews one about,
I don't want anybody to learn anything about you.
I just want to give you a break from the same fucking 20 questions,
but I'm so happy for you man.
Thank you buddy.
That means a lot to already done so much brilliant work in the fact that,
you know,
HBO shout out to them for being so cool to let a comedic actor,
I don't know how to define what,
what,
what it is sketchy.
I don't know how,
I just know comedian what,
what,
what do,
you know,
like sketch actor to SNL and they let you do something like that as a pen to
write it and direct.
I never,
never
directed before and they let me direct stuff and I mean,
uh,
you know,
I directed the first three episodes and to write and all that and so yeah,
just to be able to have so much faith and it's crazy.
Eddie Murphy 48 hours steadfast.
Yeah.
The acting that he does in that he so God damn funny,
but when it has to be real,
he's incredible.
And then what was,
what was the one he got nominated for the,
uh,
dream girls?
I,
for the life of me,
I don't understand why he doesn't get more stuff.
He,
I will say a bit,
but that 48 hours scene when he goes into the redneck bar and he,
you know,
the cowboy is one of the few scenes in movie history where you're like,
that's a movie stars just been born.
Yeah.
We're,
what,
with one scene,
it's very rare where you can go,
you know,
like John Wayne and stage coach,
they always say they push in on in his first shot and stage coach and everybody
went,
wow,
who was that guy?
You know?
But Eddie Murphy in that scene,
I just remember,
I remember I didn't see it,
but my,
my dad's seen them.
We've been coming back and going,
there's this guy in the movies,
the new guy on SNL.
It is like one of the funniest things.
He's phenomenal.
You got
to see,
you know.
Yeah.
What else?
I I,
that is the best gun sounds.
Oh yeah.
Walter Hill's movies always have like the cannon.
Unbelievable.
And you know something.
I actually,
uh,
got to do an acting gig where I,
I played,
uh,
um,
ah,
fuck.
I'm so bad with the named Jason.
Uh,
he played Mike on Breaking bad.
Oh,
I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he's great.
I got to talk,
I got to talk to him about being on 48 hours.
Uh,
he's like,
God dammit.
Jacked up,
joke,
don't.
He goes to,
he gives him the gun and then he also got thrown over the,
the buffet table,
um,
in a,
in Beverly hills cop and he hasn't been one of my favorite lines in airplane.
Oh,
he was in an airplane?
Yeah.
He goes,
the guy just went from 500,000 feet to 20,000 feet.
What an answer.
He's the guy in the radio or watching like,
yeah.
This guy to see that again.
Yeah.
He just,
the cutaway to him,
he was like,
oh,
it just went from,
it's like,
yeah,
25,000 feet to 7,000 feet.
What an ass.
I remember that line was him.
Yeah.
He's also the guy that go,
how are we doing?
And he opens up a,
it's a like a Turkey and then he's like,
oh,
we're almost done.
We're almost finished here,
sir.
So just dumb.
But he's great.
I mean,
that's one of the best of the best movies.
But yeah,
no,
the gun,
the gun sounds in 48 hours.
All those Walter Hill movies.
He always had like a really cool sound design in his movies.
He was great.
Yeah.
The whole thing.
I actually one time went,
whoa,
this is like the epilogue of the plug.
Just this point.
I was on the subway and the actor that played Luther,
you know,
the guy from warriors,
he was sitting like right across from me.
He had,
you know,
he looked great.
I mean,
it was like maybe 20 years ago I saw him.
Wow.
What am I just the way he delivered that line,
uh,
when he,
when Nick Nolte,
he's beaten him up at the door and he goes,
you know,
like,
well,
I think you're lying.
And the line is,
yeah,
well who gives a fuck what you think?
And he doesn't yell to the Word Fuck.
He just goes,
yeah,
well who gives a fuck what you yell at Fuck?
Who gives a fuck what you think?
Oh,
there's a fuck when you,
that's the way he did that.
He has that catch phrase in my family.
Yeah.
Who gives a fuck what you,
yeah.
He has such weird rhythms.
That guy all the warriors to,
I mean like,
he's such a,
he has such a cool way of speaking.
You just hear like,
yeah,
well you can learn a lot from that guy and people are going to learn a lot from
you watching this.
Uh,
this,
this Sunday's episode,
or go on Hbo.
Go to check it out.
Barry starring Bill Hader.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for coming on the podcast.
Thank you buddy.